- [Kelly] What do your
kids think about the book?
Are they excited about it?
Like, my girl didn't get it for a while,
that it was named after her.
Like, I have one and she
didn't get it for a while.
Now, she thinks it's super cool,
but what do your kids think?
- They didn't get it either.
Like, you get to the end of the book
and then it'd be like, "Mommy,
why are you in the book?"
- [Kelly] Why is your picture? Yeah.
- They didn't, yes,
exactly the same thing,
didn't get it at all.
And then, sometimes he'll be...
Milo will literally like hold my face
and he'll do this thing where he holds it
and gives me a big smooch and he goes,
"Mom, that was a movie star kiss.
It's so lovely, I love this book."
And then other times he, because he's,
obviously because he's a four year old,
it's slightly Jekyll and Hyde
and you never really know what
you're going to get, right?
- Yes, amen.
And so, the one night
he says to me, "Mom".
He's a bit like a teenager at this point,
"Mom, you know in your book,
it says I can do anything."
I said, "Yes, Milo, you can,
if you put your mind to
something and you find
something you love and
you want to work hard,
you can do anything you want to do".
And he's like, "Well,
that's not true, is it"?
- Oh, no.
- "Well, what do you mean?"
He says, "Well, that's not true,
because what I want to do is,
I want to take a koala home
from the zoo, bring it
here, and keep it as a pet.
I can't do that, can I, mom?"
- He's very literal.
- And through my head, I'm going,
"Cat Deeley's kid kidnaps
koala and kills it from zoo".
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah.
- You know, like, I'm thinking that.
And I'm like, "Oh, no,
no, you can't do that.
You can't do that".
I said, "But what you can do..."
And you know in those,
and I'm sure we've all
had those moments where,
you know, when they ask
you something and your
brain is like racing,
trying to find the right answer
and you can almost hear your brain work.
And it's like...
It's almost like a drum roll
for when you come up with the answer
and you're going as fast as you can.
And I said, "No, Milo, you
absolutely can't do that".
I said, "But what you can
do, is if you go to school
and you study really
hard and maybe you might
study something called Biology
and then you can study
something called Zoology
and go to university, then you could be
in charge of all the koalas at the zoo.
Or you could even travel to
the other side of the planet
which is as far as you
can get to Australia
which is where koalas come from
and you could go to a sanctuary
and you could help koalas
who don't have a mom and
dad and you can feed them.
- Great answer!
- [Cat] And I just...
(Cat sighs)
And I left it like that
and I was, in my head,
I was like high-fiving myself
and all the rest of it.
And he just looked at me like that.
- [Kelly] He's like, "Not the same".
- "All right, mom."
"All right, mom. All right."
- "I guess I'll accept that answer."